you want to have some fun go see this
movie sitting right next to an old man
that was interesting bombs shame stars
Michael Fassbender and Carey Mulligan
and Michael Fassbender 2011 was his year
I mean he was in everything and
everything he was and he killed it I
mean he was just so good in every movie
he was in and so many people are calling
him the new Marlon Brando and all these
things like you know Michael Fassbender
microphone I'm your boss matter and I am
on the train of Faust mender because
this guy is brilliant Sam is about a guy
who's basically addicted to women taking
him home and you know it's just that's
what he does every night he goes to a
bar tries to find a woman tries to find
someone to pick up he goes in the subway
she's a woman it's all I can think about
he just has this issue this very serious
addiction to this and it's not even
something he enjoys anymore there are
many times in the movie where you can
see that this guy is just breaking I
mean everything about him is just
falling apart he doesn't find any
enjoyment or pleasure in being with a
woman at all anymore
he's kind of like Ryan Gosling's
character from Crazy Stupid Love except
he's not happy and he's kind of going
insane a little bit Faust bender in this
movie just blew my mind I mean I really
think he's really of an Oscar his
performance is so realistic and he's
able to transmit you know thoughts just
help help the audience to understand
exactly what he's thinking without
really saying anything just in his
facial expressions the movie is also
directed extremely well by Steve McQueen
no not the guy from Bullitt but the
director then be kind of cool with the
actual Steve McQueen directors for
wouldn't I better be a little bit
different they're probably a huge
chasing the middle the movie very hard
new you
Carey Mulligan is also very good as his
sister who crashes his house and comes
over and decides to try to stay with him
for a long time because she doesn't have
anywhere to stay and things get really
complicated because of that because
Michael Fassbender's daily routine
essentially is just pleasing his own
desires in every aspect of the word I'm
not just talking about women he's a very
kind of a selfish person and he doesn't
want to have anyone around him and so
that creates this serious issue this is
a really good movie and it's it's not a
movie that I will really recommend to
anyone to be honest just decide if you
want to watch this movie I'm just going
to say that it's it's a really well
acted movie a really well directed movie
a very disturbing movie the visual
hinting of what is going on behind these
people's minds and everything is really
strong in this movie and visual
storytelling is really the best sign of
a good director when he can get you to
understand exactly what he's trying to
portray without the characters having
said anything and that's very strong
here in this movie if I can make it
there was like an audience member behind
me I swear he had his pants off I don't
know it seemed like he was getting ready
to do something I don't I heard him
making noises it was awkward it was just
a weird situation I thought maybe I
should check the back of my head to see
if there's anything there that resembled
hair gel is that hair gel yeah moving on
from that situation I will say this is a
very well acted movie a very well
directed movie a very well written movie
and it's just one of those movies where
leave you feeling a little bit cold
about life but you respect the way the
film was made by far the best part of
this movie is Michael Fassbender the guy
is amazing he's truly an excellent actor
very well made I'm gonna give Shaymin a
- it's up to you
so what's your guy's opinion at Michael
Fassbender I want to know you guys think
of them because I think the guy's
insanely brilliant so let me know down
to stuckman square what you think of the
guy cuz I think it's pretty awesome if
you like this review you can subscribe
to my channel and get steppen eyes